pour rassurer ceux qui sont exposés tous
les jours ou virus la mairie de denain
dans le nord a décidé de rouvrir la
piscine et de mettre à disposition ses
douches objectif permettre à ceux qui
travaillent de se décontaminer avant de
rentrer chez eux d'avoir réservé aux
soignants l'initiative s'est élargi à
toutes les personnes au contact de la
population et donc potentiellement au
coronavirus émile-legault gâche et
caroline beac un sas de décontamination
c'est ce qu'est devenue la piscine de
denain sur décision de la mairie
le personnel soignant mais aussi
d'autres professionnels en contact avec
le co vite 19 peuvent s'ils avaient
avant de rentrer chez eux
il s'agit d'éviter qu'ils ne contaminent
leurs proches une mesure qui leur permet
d'être plus rassuré y avant de regagner
leur domicile
c'est ce que nous explique ses deux
ambulanciers l'impression de rentrer
chez nous en fait les décontaminer
quelque part voilà ça fait partie de
2 2
du processus pour en terminer notre
journée avec ça et et puis après on est
plus en avant de pouvoir prendre une
douche il faut suivre la procédure pour
passer d'une zone dite salle
c'est à dire la zone potentiellement
contaminés à une zone propre des sacs
plastiques sont mises à disposition pour
les chaussures et les vêtements
une femme de ménage est présente sur
place pour désinfecter les lieux tout
est minutieusement nettoyer à chaque
passage pour la maire de denain la
transformation de cette piscine en sas
de décontamination répondait à un besoin
du personnel médical et c'est eux qui
les premiers ont interpellé j'ai des
amis infirmières médecins me racontant
dont les premiers cas qu'ovide qu'il
traitait à la maison la peur qu'ils
avaient de rentrer chez eux
et quand les enfants arrivent pour dire
bonjour un bisou un câlin c'était la
crainte de devoir filer finalement ce
virus très contagieux à tout le reste de
la famille toutes les personnes qui
ressentent le besoin de se décontaminer
peuvent venir sur place des caissiers du
personnel de sécurité ou encore des
kinésithérapeutes se rendent désormais à
la piscine de denain une initiative qui
permet de rassurer de nombreuses
personnes pour lesquelles le télétravail
est impossible